as we come on the air on this tuesday
edition of pft pm there is yet another
news nugget andy dalton aka
the red rifle remember the time j.j watt
butchered his nickname after a
monday night win by the texans over the
bengals anyway he will now be rifling
for
according to adam shafter of espn the
chicago bears
instant analysis because we didn't know
about it 30 seconds ago
good afternoon peter what do you think
of dalton to the bears
well mike i mean there's three very
quick points number
one i guess this means that all those
people who thought that russell wilson
was a lock to go to the chicago bears
and they had so many great things to
trade didn't they mike
the 20th pick in the draft i mean that
is so
valuable isn't that worth a hall of fame
quarterback
the 20th pick in the draft i was feeling
there would have been more
added to it once they restricted there
would have been a little bit
that but the case was away once again
structured khalil mack
yeah right right but anyway so the first
thing is
russell wilson now okay but the second
thing
is that you know at some point
you've got to stop dreaming about who
your quarterback is going to be
washington stopped dreaming last night
about 10 o'clock
and they said okay we're going to camp
and one and our quarterback
is most likely going to be ryan
fitzpatrick
or taylor heineke tyler heineke taylor
tyler whatever
but so they they stopped dreaming
last night about what might happen okay
the chicago bears today stopped dreaming
and got into reality and said
we better get the best possible guy who
we can to quarterback our team this year
so now they go to camp probably with
foals and andy dalton may the best man
win
and i think the third thing to say is
andy dalton did a good job with his
opportunity in dallas last year it
didn't show up in the one loss column
but he played credibly for a team
that at the time he went in the lineup
was a bad
team and he made it better second round
pick of the bengals in 2011 this is year
number 11 for andy dalton the bengals
cut him loose
last season in advance of drafting joe
burrow first overall and then he landed
with the dallas cowboys and did play
a decent amount after the dak prescott
injury he had some injury issues of his
own
dalton did he had a covet 19 stint
as well but 10 million dollars for one
year that matches the base value that
washington is giving
to ryan fitzpatrick i don't think it
necessarily takes the bears
out of play at number 20 just like
fitzpatrick doesn't take
washington out of play at number 19 but
what it does
it makes it less obvious that they may
be thinking quarterback
it would have been obvious if neither of
these teams had signed a veteran
to a contract that screams we're willing
to let this guy play for a year
so i think the bears depending upon who
slides through the teens
still in play at 20 just like washington
peter's still in play at 19.
well who is in play at that time
probably mac
jones only and that's a very big maybe
you'd really have to be in love with mac
jones
because to me i i don't think mac jones
is going to be there at number 19.
i think you're going to have to trade up
to the middle of the round or to the
very early teens
to have a chance to get mac jones but be
that as it may
what this says today is that everyone in
the league knows right now
that these top four quarterbacks in this
draft are not getting out of the top ten
they're just not so you don't have a
good chance
to get trey lance unless you blow up
your draft in the next two years
or you don't have a good chance to get
justin fields
unless you want to blow up your draft in
the next couple of years
so that is what both of these moves tell
me
the move at number 19 of washington to
get ryan fitzpatrick in the move at
number 20
where they are drafting this year
washington and chicago 19 and 20
at 20 the bears to get andy dalton and
andy dalton did take the bengals to the
playoffs five straight years to start
his career
the guy has done some good things he's
never won a playoff game but
uh you know it's not like the bears have
a long history of franchise quarterbacks
he comes in there and he gives them
stability potentially and some
credibility yeah there was a report last
night that the bears were interested in
jameis winston well given that the
saints signed him to a base contract of
5.5 million
for 2021 they could have had jameis
winston if they were going to pay 10
million
for their veteran quarterback dalton
ends up being the guy it comes at a time
when the 49ers
were reportedly very interested in andy
dalton and now the bears
have something that they can say
okay here we go this is our guy let's
see what we can do
and let's try to put something together
and make some chicken salad out of a
situation where everyone's job
potentially is on the line peter and and
look
we'll see look they could have done a
hell of a lot worse than andy dalton i
know that's not a ringing endorsement
but it's true they could have done a
hell of a lot worse and you can argue
for the past couple of years they have
done worse
than what andy dalton could do for them
and look you put it this way i would
assume
that they will hang on to uh
nick foles but again you know this has
been such a weird off season
and it hasn't even started yet
technically
because the start of the league year it
hasn't even started
but but here's sort of the way i look at
all of this mike
it's that you know everybody has dreams
of of what they want their team to be
and what they want their quarterback
situation to be
of of everything but at the end of the
day
there's only x number of opportunities
to make your team better
and i think that the realistic thing to
do
is what both washington and chicago have
done
you know in the last 24 hours and that
is
to get a guy who you say
if we got the team around him
we can win with this quarterback both of
these teams the defense is good enough
to win uh you know to be better than 500
and to be a playoff team with those
quarterbacks playing
now will they i we just don't have any
idea
if they're going to be if the rest of
the team is going to be that good
but in my opinion both of these teams
did the pragmatic
thing not the dusty springfield wishing
and hoping thing
now timely reference now you sound like
me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports